ah you're only 19 but you've already put
out so much music when did you first
realize that you had this musicality
I've always been passionate about music
and seven little but I never really saw
it as a reality because you know neither
of my parents can sing and they're in
entertainment and they're super
challenging in their own ways but it's
like completely gone deaf can't play any
ass I just never saw it as like a
possibility that I could actually pursue
it as a career
how'd they react when you told them I
mean my mom was like what full-blown
momager in the best way you know what I
mean like without a mustache love a
momager but instantly was like showing
my music to all of her friends to all
that's how I met my first manager oh
really now yeah when I was like 12
because they work together and we the
superest and then she showed him oh my
god yeah but I don't know they they have
supported me since the beginning they've
been so you know my number one fans and
it's cool I think I'm very very lucky
growing up with the parents that I grew
up with because you know they work in
art and they're both so passionate about
their jobs so all they want for their
kids is to find something that you know
we're passionate about so people are
really loving navy blue and also why do
you love me how's the reception been for
you conversations in the silent water
violin and the feel starry and slow we
don't even try to hide it it's like it's
been overwhelming I I just love all the
reactions and and everybody you know
listening to it and even just tagging me
and Instagram and all my fans who know
all the words and make their own videos
I don't know it's been it's been
overwhelming because I you know again
I've been making music for a bit but I'm
still like new to the game I'm still
only 19 I'm still finding my sound and
it's still you know it's hard for me to
fully be like okay this is a hundred
percent me wait no but I like this sound
this is me and it's I feel like I'm
finally making the music that I love and
I would listen to it even if it wasn't
me so it's like you know there's a
little bit more of a vulnerability to
releasing yeah like the latest stuff are
you someone who's constantly writing and
like fine
inspiration they are a life yeah always
I'm I mean I'm a singer-songwriter at
heart I used to just it was just me and
my guitar me and on piano and I would
just write the saddest yeah it's
depressing love songs at like 11 years
old me it had literally my I had no idea
what love was that I was just always so
obsessed with writing and writing
emotions and being really like open and
vulnerable you know on paper and and I
still had that today I'll think of
something the middle of the day and I'll
write it down on my phone or or just yes
I'm one-liner it's like anything I think
you know that comes in my head that I'm
like oh that's interesting yeah this is
what I feel right now I'll write it down
I think it's important to do you mom
here like beeps and sounds when you
think of lyrics yeah more so like chords
cornellà T's because again it's like at
my core I write everything honestly
every song that you've heard whether it
be why do you love me or navy blue or
everybody loves you or like a super pop
song sleep-talking they all started just
with a guitar or just with a piano
that's how all my songs start and I
think you know in my opinion the best
song can be played acoustically and
still sound good like very stripped down
yeah I just I love that's how I write
and I've always you know written my
songs like that so when I write just in
the middle of the day I'll hear like
melodies yeah tar sands so you've worked
with amazing producers Andrew watt
Charlie puth how's that been the people
that I work with now it spit blows my
mind they're all so talented and
creative and in their own individual
ways and you know Andrew WA is a
incredible guitarist and you know he's a
producer songwriter and is amazing but
he also it's like the craziest musician
yeah I'm with Charlie he can hear stuff
that no one else can hear and it's so
crazy on the piano and with melodies and
with lyrics it's it's weird because all
these people that I've been working with
an ally tamposi and hmm he's been around
forever Julie she's writing for like
Britney Spears I feel like she's the
dopest but all these people it's like
they were my friends you know before we
even started working together and then I
go into the studio with them and I just
see like a little bit of their mind and
I'm like how do you even think of this
it's so cool because I was always also
just used to writing by myself so it's
like I'm learning so much from the
people
yeah it's amazing I'm so grateful for it
are you working on a full album are you
just gonna sort up dude oh you are yeah
okay what is it gonna sound like do a
release date I don't have a release date
yet I know there will be you know a few
more singles out before I release a
project but it's hard to tell you what
it'll sound like it's it's just very me
it's like you know the songs all will go
together in a sense but you know you'll
hear a very sad song or a very upbeat
song or you know it's I don't know it's
like a little piece of my mind it's
weird it's it's I've been you know very
influenced by rock music lately in a
great way and I I've always you know I
grew up with rock music and my parents
were the best music taste ever so I just
you know grew up on Joni Mitchell or
Chili Peppers and Beatles all that stuff
and I finally feel like would these
people that I'm working with I'm able to
express myself through my music with
that rock inspiration better than I ever
could have because I just didn't really
know how to yeah I mean so yeah you'll
hear a lot of more real guitars and real
drums and pianos I feel like you have
kind of a haunting sound about you and
you are getting comparisons have you
heard this yet - Billie Eilish yeah here
how do you feel about that I mean I love
it she is incredible I think she's so
innovative and kind and loving and
talented and it's really cool I've
noticed as she's been younger and and to
watch her thrive and explode she's like
the biggest in the world it's just the
coolest thing ever it's sick
so you met her amazing yes and you've
known her since before she sort of took
off yeah and she's she's just she
deserves everything that she you know is
getting right now I think she's so
talented I think she's one in a million
and she's very individual and it's I
feel you know when everybody compares me
I'm like oh well thank you and she's the
most just I think she's setting a path
it's like when people talk about Lana
Del Rey that it's like or Avril Lavigne
and those type of pop stars that kind of
and yeah with a rock edge that like set
their own path you know what I mean that
it's like there wouldn't be 200 of these
famous pop stars without these people I
think that Billy's
our generations like you know first of
many together you could be one of those
what is your place to you in the music
industry I don't know I don't know
that's a hard question
i-i-i just I love creating and I love
writing and I love singing it's like
I'll do this you know for the rest of my
life if I don't get paid a dime all I
really care about is just to be able to
you know express myself through my music
and in a sense I look at it that's like
a therapy you know what I mean I get out
my emotions and and write about my
stories or things that happened to me or
around me or anything like that and then
I put it out into the world and I hope I
can affect at least just one person
whether it be positively or have them
you know feel like I'm taking the words
out of their mouth it's I don't really
know what my place is per se but I know
that I just want to make people feel
something well I think they do because
your lyrics are very relatable because
they are so personal and I'm saying so I
feel like you can check that box tour
you're going on to our very soon what
can fans expect from the live show oh my
gosh it's so fun this time around I'm so
excited I'm gonna be playing electric
guitar I'm playing piano it's the
craziest light I can't dance and dance
cuz I'm ten feet tall and I have like a
wingspan yeah ten feet but I you know
move around and we're all gonna be
jumping and having fun it's just gonna
be a lot of fun all I'm playing all the
good old stuff but like new stuff too
and stuff that'd than out there yeah we
good yeah feel like kind of test it I'll
test so cool at least like one or two
weeks settles don't switch it up what do
you bring on tour with you and who do
you bring I bring my two electric
guitars one acoustic guitar I need a
brand new pair of sweatpants because ask
my entire team it's honestly pretty
gross and I don't know why I'm admitting
this but it's like if I have one good
pair of sweatpants and a sweatshirt I'll
literally wear it every single day for
the entire tour it's ridiculous it's
like last time I had this huge NASA
sweatshirt and it was like chocolate and
by the end of it like chocolate
like doughnuts it was really good time
to turn away hi I'm 2/3 of way I just am
very like I write and I stay up it's bad
and nobody listen to me you know
anybody's going to are watching this
don't do this I stay up until like 4:00
in the morning writing and just in my
little bunk coz you feel like you're in
like a coffin yeah oh that's heavy I
wouldn't expect creepy Boston actually I
don't
it's it's dark and like inspirational in
a way I don't know how to describe it
it's like you're moving on a moving bus
and I wake up at like 4:00 p.m. roll out
of bed in my pajamas go straight into
soundcheck do the show have the best
time and then right back into pajamas
same routine yeah do your parents go
with you on tour no at this point no but
and they've never before but there again
my number one fans so they travel around
to come see me I'm very excited or my
grandparents are like flying for Canada
this year it's gonna be [ __ ] so fun
because of who your parents are do you
feel like you have to work extra hard to
sort of prove yourself or has it been
easier in so many ways I feel like it
has been easier for me than obviously
many other people and I'm so grateful
for you know the childhood that I have
and the parents that I had that raised
me very well and we were always
comfortable and happy and they supported
my music and you know would do anything
in their power to make me succeed in
that sense of you are so amazing and
something I'm so grateful for but
there's also you know an aspect of that
that's their their own people and and
I'm obviously well they're not musical
they're not yeah oh they're in
television and it's like there's only so
much you know they can help me with it's
like they don't know this world and and
I'm still learning it as well and I want
to be able to do it myself and since
I've been a musician even with their
emotional support and you know them in
the crowd at every show even if it was
450 people whatever it may be it is all
me and I work I work my ass off and I
can say that confidently yeah you know
and I I want to be you know my own
musician and
not connected to them in that sense it's
like everything that I've you know
gotten or opportunities or anything like
this at this point in my life is because
it mean and they would say that too but
yeah
I am grateful though for the amount of
support I have from them and and
everything yeah you do run with a very I
would say cool group of friends who do
you think has been the most supportive
of your career oh how do you guys
support each other even I mean we all
support each other I have the best with
the friends of all time it's like
there's never been any competition never
been any jealousy some of my best
friends I've grown up with and I've
known seven five years old and whether
they're in fashion and music in acting
whatever it may be it's like we all you
know we all support each other and love
each other and and I feel you know very
grateful every day for the group of
friends that I'm surrounded by and it's
cool too because I feel like as a
creative person you kind of gravitates
you know you gravitate toward like you
will like me so it's like all my friends
are so creative and interesting and
smart but in their own way it's like I'm
not you know I don't know how to
describe it it's like we're all connect
over that but none of us have the same
job really it's like Oh kinda different
it's is there one friend who sort of has
helped you or given you advice about how
to navigate the same aspect of it as
your career starts getting bigger and
bigger I don't know not really we never
really talked about that it's like you
know no matter how famous or how
whatever you are it's like we're all
equal and you know if you're kind and
and loving and a good friend it's like
that's all that good that's all that
really matters but yes all my friends
you know do give me good advice and even
just watching them navigate their own
world hmm
even if they're at a level of Fame
that's like crazy hard to understand
yeah it's cool to watch and and
use that as like a little role model are
you ready for that next level of
superstardom for you I don't know I
don't expect it now I just want to keep
creating yeah I mean if it comes it
comes and I'll be like okay but I've
never thought about it I never expected
it I was never the kid that was like I
want to be famous
oh yeah i'ma to write and playmate in
your day yeah is you been talking and
you say is there anything that you won't
write about like anything that's too
hard to write about or that you know
he's off limits not really no I kind of
write about anything which is scary to
say but I used to be very closed off in
the sense of you know if anything was
actually serious going on in my life I
literally would not talk about it to
anybody and I was like the most
extroverted crazy kid but I just would
never talk about real stuff for some
reason yeah and when I found writing I
was able to actually talk about you know
things that were happening that may be
sad or made me angry or frustrated or
heartbroken whatever it may be and put
it into lyrics and show it to people
so yeah I don't really think there's a
limit honestly you're very busy and I
feel like your career is getting bigger
and bigger I mean you have tour
how do you balance that with like a
personal life or do you I mean my
personal life is my music you know what
I mean okay but I mean I think I balance
it it's like I will go to the studio and
work work work and then I'll go straight
to a friend's house well the sleepover I
wake up
you know go to this video I don't know
it's it's a very weird cycle but with
touring it's a little different because
it's like you go on tour and you're just
completely separated from your entire
life you do feel like life sort of goes
on without you and then you come back
and you're like wait what's been I not
really even you just kind of feel like
you're taken out of it for a second it's
like tour is this whole weird world it's
like you're living on a bus and the
people around you or your family now and
your best friends and it's like I
literally when I go on tour I couldn't
care less about what's going on at home
and obviously you know I talked to my
best friend
in short I'm seeing a dude and whatever
it may be it's like I said my family I
still keep in contact with people that I
love and stuff but it's like I don't
care about any drama that's going on I
don't care about anything it's just kind
of like I'm in this like the biggest
drama that I'll face is like oh my god
there's no bagels in this city like what
how are we gonna find coffee and bagels
like that's like the biggest drama
I need cream cheese literally it's like
you just you fall asleep in your little
coffin bed and then yeah I got
performing and I also just so lucky
because it's like my band and my tour
manager and everybody around me it's
just family and I've been with them
they've been with me for I think two
years now so it's there's any people
like every dude what yeah and I love oh
so lucky than that
speaking of your personal life there was
a rumor that you were dating somebody
and then that sort of got squashed how
do you handle like headlines do you even
read them no I don't look down cell
phone I don't look at tag pictures of me
I'm very like trying to stay separated
yeah is that sort of the way that you
feel like you want to navigate this I
don't know I think that I think that you
know technology and his senses is good
for us you know and and teaches us new
things and like you can learn so much
that you've never been able to learn all
that stuff the audio to but I don't know
I do think that headlines in that sense
and like you know talking about right
yeah yeah yeah I don't know I think that
that can be negative because you know a
lot of things are true a lot of things
aren't true I don't know it all gets
mixed up and I just I would rather put
myself out of it and live my life
without having yeah anybody else try to
speak for it
it is weird that once you sort of like
enter this industry that the focus would
have becomes about that kind of yes
that's frustrating and like there that's
definitely frustrating is that you know
it's like people all people want to know
is like the gossip in there yeah he and
and the negative stuff rather than like
listen to my music exactly yeah
what do you want people to know about
you
as you start getting bigger and my gosh
I don't know that I write my own stuff I
think is something that I really just
wanna you know express to people because
obviously there's some amazing
incredible artists that don't write
their own stuff but still can express
themselves through their voice so if
their instruments or whatever it may be
that's something that I you know take to
heart is yeah I write yeah I love that
will tell the fans where they can listen
to your music where they can catch you
on tour I mean guys just look up
Charlotte Lawrence on anything and
you'll hear me I'm going on tour on the
six I'm going to Atlanta and then you've
a bunch every night oh yeah la New York
we're or next year too yeah yeah going
on tour also in March all around Europe
and I think I'm going to Russia GE whole
thing yeah that's amazing I'm so excited
for you thanks so much for coming in you
thank you for having I love the music I
think it's great you're gonna just get
bigger and bigger yeah so thank you
[Music]